dans les vignes de la haye fouassière
on s'affaire met les mains dans la terre
jo landeron a repris le domaine viticole
de son père en 1979
tranquillement ils s'orientent vers le
bio puis la biodynamie et transforme le
muscadet paternel en un vin plein de
nuances
où
dans le pays nantais ont produit du
muscadet je veux landreau lui produit
des muscadet pourquoi parce qu'un vent
c'est avant tout une histoire de terroir
sur l'exploitation familiale on
travaille sur trois types de sols et là
où on est ici sur sur ce plateau là on
est sur des roches vertes en fait
d'aider des remontées de roches vertes
qu'on appelle les amphiboles it qui
produisent un jus qu'un équilibre un peu
particulier avec toujours ce côté très
très citronnée bien sûr qu'on est bien
le muscadet qui rafraîchissent en deux
on ne l'était revoir degrés les sables
avec les sédiments éolien sur ce que
l'argile de détroit on a les orthodoxes
et les quartz avec nous un lieu dit
qu'on appelle le fief du breuil où on
est dans un autre monde du vin coincé on
passe une autre étape
on l'aura compris le muscadet n'est pas
qu'un petit blanc sec avec lequel on
déguste des autres tout dépend de la
terre mais aussi de la façon dont on la
travaille ici ici 1 2 3 4 5 6 et 7
j'ai découvert la biodynamie chez les ch
et des collègues vignerons d'autres
vignobles ya toujours eu cette volonté d
d'aller vers une culture le plus naturel
possible de culture biologique
mais en travaillant en bio justement au
niveau des vignobles je me suis rendu
compte aussi qu'on peut aller un peu
plus loin que ça nous donne les fils
auquel que je tourne des tags
non mais non des fois tu as regardé un
vin est au final une histoire de
rencontres et dans les vignes les
échanges vont bon train entre les 80
vendangeurs venus d'ici ou d'ailleurs
mon grand frère il est identique les
semblables avaient pas bon c'est réveil
très tourmentée pour le chien ouais il a
plus ou moins vecteur des cafés 20
hectares de café vecta des cafés allez
on arrête de causer et on coupe
pour joe landeron la biodynamie est
aujourd'hui bien plus qu'une pratique de
vignerons ça n'est pas une finalité
c'est un cheminement et je pense que
dans un cheminement ya jamais de nous il
ya jamais d'issue donc faut des outils
c'est comme pour monter un escalier faux
démarche
on va dire c'est une étape